[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to another episode of
bleacher reports pre-game picks
the only show in the world where we give
you the people at home
chances to win free cash prizes by
simply predicting all the random [ __ ]
that occurs in the nba pregame
tonight we live from new orleans with
the pelicans versus the lakers and me
and loser giving y'all a lot of money so
stay tuned
and let's get to these pics baby yes sir
let's get it
lois
let's get it boom i told you how crazy
is that wait is that a three let's see
that's a three that's a three step curry
wow my name i told y'all welcome to
pregame picks
let's get it
as always welcome back to another
episode of pregame picks
i am your host pierre aka p with a plug
and i got my right hand man 100 grand my
brother from another
famous and the builder lost was popping
brody
big p what's up brother how we living
let's get it a d back
let's do it b a d back a d
a d back we got some more the boys are
back in town
what you do last night i want to hey hey
don't tell nobody i went to a strip club
last night i ain't been out in a long
time
you know i had to get had to get out get
a fresher breath you know
get some fresh air out you know
i feel you we gonna keep that on a low
low but before we get things started
we had the pre-prompt before before the
show
and they asking the people at home and
make sure y'all comment too
while lost let me know his response are
the lakers
title hopes [ __ ] with lebron james
injury
loss are they good are they in trouble
oh
okay okay no the floor
because brian brian i don't think is it
is it is it
is it out for good injury did they say
that no
but it's multiple weeks and the
dangerous thing about the ankle thing
because and i can speak off experience
because i had an ankle injury
um in high school that was real severe
is that if you don't break your ends
your ankle like the timetable is
uncertain it could
be three weeks it could be six or seven
it's a high ankle sprain so
yeah you know the doctors told me when i
had mine the best thing to do is to
break it so then you can get the surgery
you put it in the cast
for three to four weeks it's back and
you back out there but when it's when
it's high ankle sprain it just got a
hill on its own so i don't know lois
i don't know no i don't know but i think
brian's gonna come back i think ryan
will be back and he'll be ready i think
he'll be back he'll
be ready though that's why i say that's
why i say their chances ain't gonna be
you know you know out of here because
brian ain't never been hurt like that
for real you feel me
that's a fact that's a fact and on top
of that as we see
we got we had a.d on the court today
warming up he should be back in what
about two weeks
you know what i mean that should change
the dynamic he can hold it down and get
him some some type of stability
if lebron has um you know a a large
return table can we see some of that a.d
warming up on the court
i think we no a.d no a.d
that's scary no a.d no bro
that's my question for you lost without
a.d and without lebron james
that leaves us with
and i'm gonna be real with you cool's
low-key nice as hell
cool's looking nice as hell but he but
he behind a.d
and and uh lebron and woo woo but cools
if cools really start
he supposed to be nice as hell don't be
honest with you bro
okay that every girl warming up is it
any coincidence that we got a.d
on the court warming up backing the ones
is that a coincidence
or that he just got a he just had to
touch that floor to rub it in ain't face
that he back in the building
because you know they ain't they had it
he still got it
he's showing him he's still got it but
he ain't worried about that man he just
won a ring
look at a.d hey d look at a d
hey hey chicago and we get we get love
everywhere baby
we get love everywhere baby yes sir but
yeah
trying not to get zion to play
yeah a.d we get love um chicago once we
get love
everywhere um i want to say shout out to
them
he said we give him hey shout out to big
fern
he said if that high ankle sprain
lingers into the playoffs
and a.d doesn't come back fully healthy
then yes
the uh this might be utah's year i i
personally
um don't think that'll happen but i like
his answer he gave me i'm ben
said i've been saying and he and he gave
us
insight so big fern is taking home 200
dollars we
that's what i like even though i don't
agree with it i like insight
i like details and i like an explanation
a lot of people be out here just
throwing [ __ ] on the comments hey
i know the lakers ain't gonna make it
because i just feel like that or
lebron his his injury ain't gonna matter
cuz i'm just a laker fan so i love
details and explanation so big fern
you're taking home
200 to start the night we amp like that
yes sir baby i like it yeah
yeah we we lit from joe 200 from jump i
love it i love it
look at coos get right cruz hey zion if
you're like exciting bro i don't miss no
i don't miss no zion games bro i don't
miss no zion games they're keeping it
hot with your zion like that
hey now yeah yeah we don't miss zion
games
i don't know what that is every time he
play he use that stretcher pole
is he gonna use it tonight what you
think he's gonna use it uh yeah
yeah he gonna use it yeah he gonna use
it facts
thanks yeah if you agree with me in the
comments
drop in the comments yes or no rock with
me and lost we've done a lot of these
pelican games
lost about to say this damn near 100
you're gonna use it that's what you're
gonna say
yeah it's 100 he gonna use it
i'm waiting to see if he i'm waiting to
see what he's gonna i got some [ __ ] for
you if he do use it
is that him pulling it out no no that's
not him yeah
thank you it's a part of the process bro
it's a part of the one-month it get him
going bro
he ain't changing it up
[Music]
hey this would be tonight he don't do it
he maybe he said hey maybe he said i
don't see lebron or a.d down there i
ain't got to pull that [ __ ] out tonight
it's going to be a light night no no no
if it will need light nights he needs to
be saying lebron
ad ain't out there i'm about to go for
70.
that's what he needs
between me and you who gonna leave the
lakers and scoring tonight whoever
closer me or you
the other one got to do 50 jumper jacks
on the next show who you got
the lakers leading scorer hey hey that's
tough as hell
uh but i would give it tres tres
you wanna give it to tres okay give me
uh yeah
they play against the pelicans i just
got word that lonzo ball and i'm playing
tonight
so give me dennis shooter i got dennis
schroeder being a leading scorer tonight
if i win you owe me 50 50 jumping jacks
if you win i owe you 50 jumping jacks on
the next episode next show
you got trailers next show yes do uh
look at drew how little all of y'all in
the comments let me know y'all what
y'all think too cause i know a lot of
y'all probably gonna say kuzma we might
have a kcp
pick let me know who y'all think is
gonna be the lakers leading scorer
tonight
without lebron a.d i'm rocking with
dennis schroeder
um schroeder however you want to
pronounce it and my boy losses right
dennis and menace
that's all you gotta say is all you guys
all you gotta say is dennis diminished
then it's the menace there we go shout
out to dennis diminished we got greek
freak little brother out there
he looked he looked like he ready for
opportunity
he didn't like him two rebounds
hey hey look that turquoise [ __ ] that
turkey that turquoise [ __ ] hot though
hey that hey that's another one that's
another one
what's what's giannis's little brother
career high rebounds since you just said
it too
which what your guess is
okay nba can anybody in production
please look up
uh giannis little brothers uh
career high and rebounds what's his
career had i think this is this is
coasters onto tucumco
not that yeah i think it ain't more it
ain't more than it ain't more than seven
though i guarantee you that ain't more
than seven though
yeah cause he had double i think hey
what the hell is he doing
i think what yeah what is he doing hey
what
what was did you stretch why are you
holding why did you stretch it white
what hell no i i just get bucket y'all
he's stretching like he's starting
while he's stretching like he's starting
hey stay ready so you ain't gotta stay
ready so you ain't gotta get ready y'all
okay
stay ready okay ready so you guys i
can't take you
i can't take you i asked oh he said why
are you stretching like right about to
start stay ready
i got his career i got it
and it ain't seven it ain't seven you
you got two more guesses
is it you can't you gotta give me my is
it higher or lower
it it it's it's below 10 but it ain't
seven you got two more guesses if you
get it right i'll do the stinky leg
right now national tv eight is eight
it's it's not eight it's lower than
seven one one last guess
oh i was five
oh you was close but it is five oh my
god what is it
rebounds that's four
in the game is for hey everybody at home
do not forget to let us know
what you think will zion be using this
famous stretch pole during warm-ups
yes or no leave it in the comments for a
chance to take home some bread
i'm rocking with yes and uh
lawson's going but yes he usually i'm
getting word that he usually does it by
now
so maybe he won't be pulling the [ __ ]
out tonight like i said he don't see
lebron
eating down there so maybe he's saying
it's a it's a it's a light night you
know what i'm saying
maybe he's saying he's getting the shots
up first he's getting the shots up first
so he's like no i got y'all yeah
before we got started i was on my phone
when we was in what like pre-production
whatever
and the trade deadline is thursday and
it's a lot of chit chat going on
so i gotta talk to my best friend what
what what you expecting to happen on
third before thursday's trade atlanta on
thursday and straight at that line
any moves you looking looking to see
make
yeah maybe happen hey ask
my people that's watching the show right
now answer for me why the warriors
ain't got nobody there he go he gonna
average the most tonight boy that's my
cousin
hey will the warriors get anybody down
why we ain't got nobody
why the warriors ain't even got nobody
even look at him
what i did hear is that back down buck
donovan's from the hoax y'all eyeing him
but what about the lakers speaking of
your cousin i saw that he was made
available with kcp and then he tweeted
the eyes emoji like he had
attitude are the lakers making any train
made
what you mean available with kcp nah he
ain't no he ain't available that'd be
dumb
that'd be dope that's what they don't
get that
i don't i don't know but that's what i
read
it was all over twitter reliable sources
they don't see
they just put look he averages they're
just putting them out in 23 why
why they going why everybody going here
averaging 23 points dawg
i'm just that's all i'm saying hey hey
my transcript who no no doubt about it
but i'm looking at a report right here
it says
the lakers have discussed trade packages
involving kentavious caldwell pope
and montrez harrell but interested teams
are also
asking for taylor horton tucker or
source tales
listen to me listen to me if a.d
averaged
20 28 lebron averaged 26
tres averaging 23 when they gone that'd
be dumb to get rid of him
damn he the heater won't score on while
they go hey
let's see i just know this we got we got
four minutes left
zayan ain't touching stretcher paul he
running to the sidelines
y'all let us know in the comments hurry
up let me know let me see
is he running today
pause is he running to that poll he just
ran to the sideline he could be running
to that poll
that's what you said she was that's what
you was doing yesterday you was running
to that poll i heard i heard
you yeah first of all
pause not like that man not like that
not like that
i'm not like that i know i know i know i
know i'm just saying but no
look just i kicked it man i kick it man
you know me i'm low-key in the spot man
i'm low-key i got that three
left-handed 3 30. ain't no [ __ ]
though i'm getting a little scared bro
i want to win my people money i'm
getting mad because i want to win my
people money i'm getting pissed off
they'll win
every game every game we covered
he doesn't have to stick now we tell the
people yes
and he ain't touched the stick yet
if you don't get your ass on that damn
stick come on bro
go get that damn stretch of hole why
zion
zion he lost hell balls
hey look look at zion muscles in that
damn shirt look at zion muscles in that
damn shirt through the shirt bro
come on dog your ass just said keep
biggest here you you are wild
uh and i literally said i literally said
pause
i literally said that but as i am
biggest as i'm as strong as
i got hella muscles in this shirt hey i
got
i gotta i gotta i gotta i gotta i gotta
bet for you
real quick right it's gonna be
spur-of-the-moment so let me know when
you're ready
yeah all ready you ready
all right yeah you got about 30 seconds
too i'm gonna let the clock get a time
that i'll be able to see
name me how you gonna eat muscles
name me three muscles that zion
stretches
when he use that pole
hamstring okay
quads
i'm not i'm not an anatomy major or
anything like that but i'm guessing
they're kind of the same but i'm gonna
let you i'm gonna let you rock
yeah that's right y'all in the comments
saying hips
say something in the comments y'all
i'm production told me you lost because
hip is not a muscle
time is uh nah the the fibrous the
fibrous
let me see hey the fibrous
what the hell is the fibrous all right
i have no idea but i wish somebody in
the comments would let us know some of
the muscles
make uh make a mess with a with a
pelican's last shot of warm-ups being
make or miss
and lost this time we're doing it
different for this episode
the past episodes we just had a lot of
a lot of issues figuring out what
exactly was the last shot
our last shot is going to be when that
clock which is now hitting the minute
hits zero everybody in the comments let
me know y'all answers right now
y'all got about 50 seconds left where
the pelicans last shot be a maker missed
lost what are you thinking is zion what
you want to do
i know all them damn muscles touch that
down cut that damn stretch and pull all
them damn muscles
sorry i'm about to really piss me off
man hey yeah
hey what you want to eat episode um
let's go uh let's go make let's go mate
let's go make somebody gonna do a layup
somebody gonna catch the rebound go back
up let's do it mate
don't let them see you blowing your nose
i low key hope they missed though i hope
they missed them to every shot this game
tous and zion didn't want to get that
stretching paul he's trying to be
careful
he said lebron i'm trying i'm trying to
win these people for money we trying to
win the money did you
you said yeah no you said yeah seven
yeah yeah six
five four three
two whatever p said whatever miss
miss miss miss miss hey miss i told you
i knew it was gonna be a myth
it's a miss it was a mess i'm getting
worried there was a mess
can i see that i
that last shot that they went up it
looked like it went in but the lights
went off
that shot was in the air before can i
get a replay
they do that i'm getting real it's
saying it's going it says
they still get some money
whoever don't better get whoever better
gets us win all right man
damn i love you don't mean that
i'm happy for the people yeah i'm happy
for the people who didn't believe in us
i'm happy for the people
yeah i say that zion pissed me off bro
i can't believe you ain't grabbed that
damn stretcher pole
that's we didn't do it this is probably
our third pelican game
so these are the five people that are
taking home five hundred dollars because
no zion did not use the stretching pole
that he has used every time we've
covered the pelicans so shout out to
bird
shout out to cuddy shout out to john
john shout out to middle name randy
they're all taking five hundred make
sure y'all get on the bleach report apps
um and get in the dms that's how you
will get your money
the next prompt will the pelicans last
shot be i make a miss
these people will win against me and
lose and i'm going to take home
200 dollars and the five winners
are jonesy 16 shout out to jonesy
we got shimmy burger we got a guy who
was like i cannot pronounce that name at
the bottom but you see it if you're up
here and then we got
infusal i don't yeah these names are
getting out of hand i was born in 1995
we don't
our names are just our names we got
flash [ __ ] i don't do all of this
random [ __ ] lois get in people with some
names bro
i don't know i know i seen 500
500 for guessing for guessing on the
poll
that's a lick that's a lick right there
hey
i i dm they might have to make me a la
burner account and start putting
a little vote in yeah that's it that's
all i said that's a lick
we appreciate y'all lost don't forget
our side back
i got uh dennis and minutes leading them
to score
trent's gonna 28 28 28.
we love y'all we'll see y'all next week
chicago hey i love y'all i love y'all i
love y'all i love y'all i love y'all i
love y'all
[Music]
[Music]
you